el pez espada y el tiburón.
Podría haber 10 veces más biomasa de peces aquí
de lo que se pensaba.
De hecho, quizás más que en todo el resto del océano combinado.
Hay un sinnúmero de especies no descubiertas en aguas profundas,
y la vida en la zona crepuscular se entrelaza con el clima terrestre.
Sin embargo, la zona crepuscular está prácticamente inexplorada.
Hay muchas cosas que todavía no sabemos al respecto.
Pienso que podemos cambiar eso.
Precisamente por este desafío fue que me atrajo la oceanografía.
Para mí representa la intersección perfecta
de ciencia, tecnología y lo desconocido;
la chispa de tantos descubrimientos sobre la vida en nuestro planeta.
Como estudiante universitaria,
hice una expedición al otro lado del Atlántico
con un equipo de científicos que usaban un láser de alta potencia
para medir algas microscópicas.
En ese viaje descubrimos algo
que todos anteriormente habían pasado por alto:
células fotosintéticas más pequeñas de lo que nadie pensó posible.
Ahora sabemos que esas pequeñas células
son los organismos fotosintéticos más abundantes del planeta.
Este descubrimiento asombroso fue posible porque usamos nueva tecnología
para ver la vida en el océano de una nueva manera.
Estoy segura de que los descubrimientos que nos esperan en la zona crepuscular
serán igualmente impresionantes.
Sabemos muy poco de la zona crepuscular porque es difícil de estudiar.
Es excesivamente grande,
va desde el Ártico hasta el océano Antártico
y alrededor del mundo.
Es diferente de un lugar a otro.
Cambia rápidamente conforme se mueven el agua y los animales.
Y es profunda, oscura y fría, y las presiones allí son enormes.
Lo que sí sabemos es fascinante.
Puede que imaginen enormes monstruos que acechan en el mar profundo,
pero la mayoría de los animales son muy pequeños,
como este pez linterna.
Y este pez de aspecto feroz es un gonostomátido.
Créase o no, son los vertebrados más abundantes del planeta
y muchos son tan pequeños que podrían caber una docena en este tubo.
Se pone aún más interesante,
porque el tamaño pequeño no les impide ser poderosos en grandes cantidades.
El sonar profundo y penetrante nos muestra que estos forman capas densas.
Pueden ver a qué me refiero por el rojo y el amarillo
que muestra este gráfico, cerca de los 400 metros.
Rebota tanto sonido en esta capa,
que se ha confundido con el fondo del océano.
Pero si lo analizamos, no puede ser, porque la capa es profunda durante el día,
asciende durante noche
y el patrón se repite día tras día.
En realidad, es la mayor migración de animales en el planeta.
Ocurre en todo el mundo, todos los días,
barriendo los océanos del mundo en una enorme ola viviente.
La población de la zona crepuscular
viaja cientos de metros a las aguas superficiales para alimentarse de noche
y vuelve a la relativa seguridad de aguas más profundas y oscuras durante el día.
Estos animales y sus movimientos
ayudan a conectar la superficie y el océano profundo
de maneras importantes.
Los animales se alimentan cerca de la superficie,
traen consigo el carbono de sus alimentos a las aguas profundas,
donde parte de ese carbono se puede quedar
y permanecer aislado de la atmósfera durante cientos o incluso miles de años.
Así, la migración puede ayudar a mantener el dióxido de carbono
fuera de la atmósfera
y limitar los efectos del calentamiento global en nuestro clima.
Pero aún tenemos muchas preguntas.
No sabemos qué especies están migrando,
qué comida están encontrando,
quién está tratando de comerlos
o la cantidad de carbono que pueden transportar.
Por eso como científica estudio la vida en el océano.
Para mí, la curiosidad sobre estos seres es un poderoso impulso,
pero hay una motivación adicional.
Debemos responder estas preguntas y hacerlo rápidamente,
porque la zona crepuscular está bajo amenaza.
Naves factoría en mar abierto
han estado aspirando
cientos de miles de toneladas de krill, pequeños animales como el camarón.
Animales que se muelen en harina de pescado
para abastecer la creciente demanda de acuicultura
y de nutracéuticos como el aceite de krill.
La industria está a punto de enviar pesquerías como estas
a las aguas de profundidad media
en lo que podría dar origen a una fiebre del oro en la zona crepuscular
por fuera del alcance de las regulaciones nacionales de pesca.
Esto podría tener impactos irreversibles a escala global
sobre la vida marina y la cadena alimenticia.
Debemos sortear los impactos de la pesca
y trabajar para entender esta parte crítica del océano.
En la Institución Oceanográfica Woods Hole, tengo la fortuna
de estar rodeada de colegas que comparten esta pasión.
Juntos, nos disponemos a lanzar una exploración a gran escala
de la zona crepuscular.
Tenemos un plan para comenzar de inmediato
con expediciones en el Atlántico norte,
donde abordaremos los grandes desafíos
de observar y estudiar la notable diversidad de la zona crepuscular.
Este tipo de exploración multiescala y multidimensional
requiere integrar nuevas tecnologías.
Les mostraré un ejemplo reciente que ha cambiado nuestra forma de pensar.
Dispositivos de rastreo satelital en animales como los tiburones
hoy nos muestran que muchos de los depredadores superiores
se sumergen regularmente a la zona crepuscular en busca de alimento.
Y al mapear sus patrones de natación y compararlos con datos satelitales,
vemos que las zonas donde más se alimentan
se vinculan a corrientes oceánicas y otras características.
Solíamos pensar que estos animales encontraban toda su comida
en aguas superficiales.
Ahora creemos que dependen de la zona crepuscular.
Pero aún hay que entender cómo encuentran las mejores zonas para alimentarse,
qué comen allí
y cuánto dependen sus dietas de las especies de la zona crepuscular.
También necesitaremos nuevas tecnologías para explorar los vínculos con el clima.
¿Recuerdan estas partículas?
Algunas son producidas por estos animales gelatinosos llamados salpas.
Las salpas son como aspiradoras súper-eficientes,
que absorben plancton y producen bolitas de excremento de rápido hundimiento.
¡Traten de decir eso 10 veces más rápido!
Bolitas de excremento que llevan carbono a las profundidades del océano.
A veces encontramos salpas en enormes enjambres.
Necesitamos saber dónde, cuándo, por qué
y si este sumidero de carbono tiene un gran impacto en el clima del planeta.
Para enfrentar estos desafíos, deberemos superar los límites de la tecnología.
Implementaremos cámaras y muestreadores en robots inteligentes
para patrullar las profundidades
y rastrear las vidas secretas de animales como las salpas.
Usaremos un sonar avanzado
para averiguar cuántos peces y otros animales hay allí abajo.
Secuenciaremos el ADN del entorno en una especie de análisis forense
para descubrir qué especies hay
y qué están comiendo.
Con tantas cosas aún desconocidas sobre la zona crepuscular,
hay una oportunidad casi ilimitada para nuevos descubrimientos.
Solo miren estas criaturas hermosas y fascinantes.
Apenas las conocemos.
E imaginen cuántas más están allí abajo
esperando que las detecten nuestras nuevas tecnologías.
Nuestro equipo de oceanógrafos, ingenieros y comunicadores
no podría estar más entusiasmado.
También tenemos un profundo sentido de urgencia.
No podemos desandar las décadas de sobrepesca
en vastas regiones de un océano
que alguna vez parecía inagotable.
¡Qué fantástico sería tomar un camino diferente esta vez!
La zona crepuscular es realmente un bien común mundial.
Primero debemos conocerlo y entenderlo
antes de poder administrarlo de manera responsable
y esperar pescar allí de manera sostenible.
Esto no es solo un viaje para científicos,
es para todos nosotros,
porque las decisiones que tomemos colectivamente
durante la próxima década
afectarán el aspecto del océano
en los siglos venideros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)